this is rajan Zed i am from nevada us
and i am president of universal Society
of Hinduism and it is a player and honor
to be at the World Economic Forum for
India which is doing a wonderful job in
bringing diverse viewpoints and diverse
topics to the forum and bringing the
people from diverse backgrounds so that
we can all work together to make india
and world a better place and the role of
religion is also to make the world a
better place and my suggestion is that
if we use a religion properly religion
can be a good friend in in making the
economies grow faster and religion can
be a good communication tour also to
spread the message of World Economic
Forum to the communities and I again
congratulate world economic forum for
doing this and I hope in future also
they will keep doing this thank you